[Music]
Chris Hogan here I've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that I run into might surprise
you whether I'm at an event or talking
on my podcast one thing has become clear
most people have no idea what a
self-made millionaire really looks like
you're going to get a glimpse into the
life of a self-made millionaire
these folks are hard at work you don't
want to miss that people this is
millionaire
irfan is next and he is in Houston Texas
afn how are you pretty good are you good
what is your net worth sir 1.3450 I'm
Nina this is my husband or fun and we're
Dave Ramsey millionaires we live in
Houston Texas we're a family of five I'm
a life coach and youtuber and I'm a
process improvement expert working in
the oil and gas so I was originally born
in Pakistan and grew up there did my
bachelor's in mechanical engineering
there then at about 93 moved to the u.s.
to do my Master's and then went on to
work for the company here and I was born
and raised in Chicago went to
Northwestern University where I received
no financial education whatsoever which
I think is a major issue with the
education in the US and I found myself
in my very early 20s a single mom making
over $100,000 and spending over a
hundred thousand dollars and then a few
years back I discovered this guy named
Dave Ramsey and as I started listening
to him and reading his books it occurred
to me that a lot of his principles were
very similar to my husband's principles
and the more I listened to him and
watched him it started thinking in I was
the problem the minute that we became in
sync our wealth grew and from that point
on is where we actually became
millionaires
to Dave Ramsey the definition of a
millionaire is you take all you have to
subtract all your liabilities and that
means equal two million dollars not
somebody who owns million dollars worth
of stuff because they may be in debt the
number one factor is actually the
savings rate right so so it could be a
millionaire you don't have to earn a lot
there are people who aren't very little
you know the average I think is around
fifty fifty thousand or less and and
with that if you have a decent savings
rate you can retire in less than a
decade but beyond that a lot of the
textbooks say you know you got to save
ten percent and that's fine but that
will get you to financial independence
in the lifetime that is expected right
the sixty five in the retirement age if
you want to be financially independent a
little bit sooner than that you got to
get up to the numbers like thirty forty
fifty sixty kind of percent and so that
is what impact is not the income so for
us very coming from our mindset is a
little bit more minimalistic a lot of
times people think that we are depriving
yourself because we are you know saving
80 percent that means that we are not
you know enjoying life at all the amount
of money that we spend still is just
focused so one of the questions we get
is what car we have so we drive two cars
and both of them be bought on cash so
that was important to me because in my
opinion if you have to finance a car
then you can't afford it so both of our
bottom cash and the idea is that we got
a drive wait till the wheels come off as
a thing but it's again one of those
things that we talk about focus so for
me car is not a big deal car is
something we just used to go from point
A to point B so it was more about
functionality and use it rather than the
Jones is the fact that you know people
are watching what car you drive so the
biggest challenge in being a millionaire
I think is is yourself you are the
biggest hurdle because the definition of
normal in the u.s. is pretty bad you
know we seventy percent of the people
living paycheck to paycheck and
unfortunately that is normal so as Dave
Ramsey says you know you got to be
comfortable being
normal abnormal should be a good thing I
think on those terms you have to
surround yourself with your like-minded
people in my real actual life I'm
surrounded by friends that are always
complaining about being broke but they
live like millionaires if you are part
of that community then find another
alternative community even if it's
online follow the Dave Ramsey show
follow him on Instagram read his books
find your community find your tribe just
slow down a little bit if you watch a
movie you know we're about to spend a
couple of hours on something we evaluate
that oh is that a good movie and a fight
because I'm concerned that I might lose
two hours we are about to spend decades
of our lives on a journey shouldn't we
take a moment you know and think about
what we're doing people buy stuff just
to get a kick out of it
and they're losing money if you can get
a kick out of saving money not a better
kick yes I hope you caught that people
don't walk away from this and let this
just be another story hard work
dedication and following the plan are
the foundation of stories just like
these stories about people who got
excited and took action and guess what
people it's your turn and I've got the
resources you need right now check out
my podcast retire inspire
[Music]
you
[Music]